foreign
they all knew this election was tight
they all knew that a Lula win would
change the political direction of Brazil
a second round a second chance but the
tension was palpable
thousands of lular supporters gathered
in Sao Paulo's police Avenue
the result like a drip feed of Hope
[Music]
at first Lula's vote started to grow
every game greeted with rapture it was
simple could he do it
but it was neck and neck to the end and
then it was done
Lula was President Kim Mayhem
[Applause]
today I'm a doctor is
today I have this it's because of Lola
everything is because of him my family
was a very poor
is there a report and today I'm I'm
living in Sao Paulo and working with the
Joby I love
I
within minutes people began flooding the
streets heading for the celebration cars
hooting horns
a complete explosion of relief and
happiness the party was now fully
underway
[Music]
Crown a remarkable comeback for a former
president
[Applause]
we just don't know
[Applause]
new spread that Lula was going to appear
after meeting his campaign and legal
teams and taking calls from world
leaders
his supporters would have waited any
length of time this was The Impossible
Dream Come True
the world needs Lula he's not the
president of Brazil he's a politician
that the world needs so it's beautiful
in vast numbers they filled Paulista as
far as the eye could see it was
impossible to guess how many people were
here it was almost impossible to move
they sang the Lula campaign songs and
waited and then he was there
and they exploded once again
I think the people must stop suffering
it's not fair for a people so kind so
affectionate a population that likes
music like Samba happy people to suffer
so much because of a fascist government
that I didn't like the people who didn't
like black people who didn't like
Indians
[Music]
whatever the idea
this has been a remarkable two-round
election which has revealed the Deep
divisions in Brazil
but this was a night of celebration for
Lula de Silva and his people he's
promised to reunite his country it's
going to be hard
still around to Sky News Sao Paulo